foreign  [Music]  brace yourselves it's reported that  Selena makes twenty thousand dollars a  day with her net worth estimated to be  around 95 million dollars can't keep my  hands to myself Selena is not only a  singer and actress she is a  businesswoman she's the founder of rare  Beauty which is reported to have brought  in 60 million dollars in Revenue just  last year why don't you recognize him  not only that Selena makes money on the  multiple TV show she not only stars in  but serves as producer on as well like  Selena and Chef and only murders in the  building Jesus is this what we're really  telling people it's a lot we could have  tightened it up in rehearsal she's also  reportedly earned 30 million dollars for  her five-year deal with puma and 10  million dollars for her work with Coach  I felt that way and we can't forget that  she's part owner of serendipity in New  York which reportedly has an annual  revenue of 16 million dollars  [Music]